I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense coming from professional sports
I and being in California you I've had
the luxury of having access to some of
the best movement people yeah out there
so through trainers yes and then you
know just out of necessity like when the
class developed it was like oh okay I
gotta figure this out and then you know
we have one of the businesses we have X
be brave you realize that right like
you're like I'm gonna have a class oh
god I gotta make up a workout they can't
even make it up for themselves if they
do it at home
yeah they'd sooner sit there it's not
that brave I think listen if you say
than you think I don't I'm more
ambitious than you think maybe then I
think if you pay attention in life and
especially when you're exposed to
environments I think you the opportunity
to pick things up is pretty real if
you're really paying attention and and I
think the willingness to say I may not
be perfect but I'm really going to give
it everything I have
that usually kind of makes things work
out well I think that that amount of
humility resonates with people right if
you said they're like you give it up on
the front end and say like okay might
not be perfect today or like oh I'm
sorry I forgot this you know forgot this
station you know right that like people
that makes you approachable well okay so
here's what I know about teaching
especially big classes is I'm not there
to show you that I can dominate you I'm
there to create an environment for you
to get a good workout in and so one part
of that is I have another side of my
personality and a character that's like
no let's not screw around why so that
the environment is set that there's
order you need order in order to execute
everything and so there's one side where
I'm like I'm not here to dominate you or
make it impossible for you and the way
I'm going to show you how much I care
about you and love you is I'm going to
keep order so that you leave with having
success and that means if anyone
threatens that order they will have a
they will hear it from me and very
quickly and
so there's it sort of twofold where
there's a part of me that's like you
know I have kicked people out of class
the joke is I have two close friends
that I'm like if you continue to talk
I'll kick you out and and they look at
me and these are my friends yeah and in
that moment I'm like yeah no try me
because what they're doing you're not
paying and there's order well and we
have 15 other people or 50 other people
that it's not about you and it's not
about me we're all gonna play by the
rules and do it so I think within it
it's like an interesting thing what do
they say being charged on in control
right I'm not here to control everybody
I'm just here to be in charge that's
where I suffer what do you mean you want
to control everything because when I see
them just doing a poor movement I'm like
oh my god yeah just do it if you hadn't
handle this through it a few more years
okay and you'll get tenderized by that
whole thing I found that one of the
things if because I've really only
taught a few classes yeah
workouts which I had a good time but I'm
a drill sergeant like I'm I see that
about I love that about you that's what
when you walked in the first day to the
workout when I my first day I was like I
love her already because you're very
strong and let's not mess around we're
here to work out we're not here to hang
out right and but I think that one of
the most difficult things other than
trying to get everyone to do everything
properly is just to make sure no one
gets hurt that's it that's that's the
key and also you have to realize half of
them are are more successful and even
have accomplished beyond what you could
want for them in a perfect push-up the
fact that they're there and I think it's
yeah recognizing that and then slowly
you go hey let's watch that and hang
watch that and they start to put it
together and by the way there's some
people who never put it together I have
people in my quiet class for eight years
I'm like still doing that move huh
pretty good okay and you just realized
sanera squat not forward fold it's just
okay it's the way it is and also again I
that's another thing about maturity for
me is everybody has their way mm-hmm
what what about you and Laird working
out together
yeah not so much
[Music]